i don't know what's being painted around
really some of this magic came to life
in unexpected ways there was the
swaddled light multiple partially built
creature heads a cgi wand oh and eddie
redmayne riding a giant puppet rig
underwater we're about to uncover all
the magic cgi brings to the world of
fantastic beasts
work with these amazing puppeteers like
some of the guys who worked on war horse
and number one they may be small but
they are feisty especially that niffler
he remains
one of newt's favorite creatures and
also the bane of his life both niffler
and the bowtruckles were inspired by
real animals zipler a cross between a
honey badger platypus and mole while
beautruckles brought serious praying
mantis and stickbug vibes niffler was
built from the skeleton up to ensure the
most realistic anatomical movements
before any cg work even started a
physical model was constructed over
multiple months for the vfx team to work
from as for the bowtruckle well that was
many months of consistent work that saw
a whopping 200 concept art versions made
before settling on the one we see in the
movie
number two a creature straight out of
greek mythology it's full of wonder in
fact this zuwu is named after the
creature that inspired it as well to
start an animation artist built the form
blending cat-like visuals and
lizard-like movements and going so far
as to see how the creature moved in the
style of a chinese dragon in a parade
when it came time to film a green man
with a marker for where the ferocious
head was meant to be filled in until vfx
could bring the magic by the end of the
process the team had spent a full year
figuring out how to capture and produce
this shot from start to finish
number three the kelpie wasn't
underwater but redmayne sure was just
because the creature didn't exist didn't
mean redmayne was going to be let off
the hook when it came to riding a kelpie
through the water the new actor was very
inexperienced when it came to actually
being underwater so he was taught how to
hold his breath for extended periods of
time by a free diver once he was ready
he dove into the deep end of the green
colored water tank literally but that's
not all a full puppet rig was set up for
the actor to ride underwater ensuring a
smooth transition when the cg was
applied and the kelpie animation was
brought to life
you bite bunty again and there'll be
trouble missing
number four
how many people does it take to make one
nagini
and then they have pure spectacle a lot
more than you'd expect and one of the
key people behind the wicked
transformation a contortionist the idea
behind nagini's tantalizing takeover was
to have the snake engulf the woman so
the team enlisted a contortionist to act
out the transformation based on the
pre-visual animation this allowed them
to capture a more realistic human
movement another contortionist performed
for the cameras but in costume literally
bending over backwards and somehow
managing to put her head through her leg
no wonder the process took place over 14
months just to nail this one detail he
will be forever
trapped in the body of a snake
number five a mating ritual never to be
forgotten while the urumpet really is
the star of this scene it was eddie
redmayne who did most of the work
filming himself doing his part of the
mating ritual to share with david yates
until they found just the right one
meanwhile the urumpet was getting
designed digitally in order for the
puppet makers to construct an 18-foot
tall 22-foot long puppet that was
operated by four puppeteers the
production filmed this scene until the
cg team had enough visual reference to
work with as for that ice redmayne
really was sliding into the scene on
such a precariously slippery surface
that the actor had to be hooked up to a
harness to make sure he didn't fall
good show mr grosski
number six terrifying on screen a bit
less so behind the scenes the terror
tina faced on screen wasn't so intense
fortunately while the particularly
threatening details were cg much of the
set was practically built
including a moving platform set up for
katherine waterston to get across to
safety oh so safely the gap was real but
it was one these actors could totally
handle
number seven
we're better for a creature to hide than
inside a suitcase before we saw just how
much that small carry-on could hold we
caught a glimpse of this animation and
of course
this creature that emerged from it that
murtlap is freakishly realistic looking
and its stand-in on set did the trick as
well even without the tentacles
number eight how can fake food look this
good
this isn't just any strudel it happens
to be one of the trickiest things to
animate in the entire fantastic beasts
franchise from intricate shading and
animated texturing to special custom
effects this dessert was a true work of
art to make sure it was as authentic as
possible the team figured out how each
of the parts would actually look moving
through the air to come together the
goal was to make it look real and they'd
definitely achieved it it's hard to
believe we couldn't sink our teeth into
that dessert number 9. this home can
take care of itself the deconstruction
of jacob's apartment saw loads of
individually animated moving pieces
while at first the team hoped to achieve
the desired effect by playing the
animation backwards it didn't look quite
right so they made use of a program
called houdini this simulated each
individual element that was being
included in the image
involved in this was everything from
railing to shelves that straighten
themselves out to laundry that hangs
itself to stairs and bricks that lay
themselves down since the reconstruction
was still a construction scene multiple
layers of dust and debris completed the
image like magic
number 10 when he woke up he chose chaos
okay so it would be super cool if ezra
miller could actually transform into
this even though it does do some serious
damage the credence actor was at the
center of all the action physicalizing
the transformation expertly for the
cameras in a practical set filled with
chaos itself from pre-built rubble
fallen pillars and of course a blue
screen so the cg transformation could
bring even more magic and chaos
number eleven you gotta work with what
you've got
even if what you've got doesn't even
come close to the creatures we end up
seeing on screen while we wish
thunderbirds were real this puppet and
human and blacks do a solid job for what
we've got
though we gotta give it to the cgt it is
far more majestic in the final cut and
of course the stand in marmite also
known as the swaddled light redmayne
made sure to hold that bundle tenderly
as he would a magical young marmite
number 12 it's goblin time
to achieve this kind of realistic
animation in the physicality and facial
movements the actor who the goblin was
based off of ron perlman spent a ton of
time doing mo-cap work to create the
physicality wanting to bring his
expression and facial details to the
character perlman got very up close and
personal with 98 different cameras set
up to capture each detail of his face
this way a 3d model could be created and
worked off of for the animation team oh
the glamour of the goblin life
number 13. whose wand isn't real the
answer is
dumbledore's that's right the wand the
jude law holds throughout most of the
crimes of grindelwald was cg because the
actual wand that had been designed for
him and was used throughout filming
looked too similar to the elder wand
since they had already wrapped filming
the team had to get creative
so they then had to cgi out that one for
like quite a substantial amount of the
film number fourteen how many layers
does it take to make a sky depends what
kind of weather you're dealing with and
when it comes to torrential and chaotic
downpours well there are a few extra
steps you've got one for general color
tone one for rain one for lightning and
clouds and even more layers to get the
shadows light and atmosphere just right
and when people whip through the sky the
cg jumps in to bring convincing
animation all around them number 15.
what's the easiest way to get to old
time in new york well other than time
traveling it's cgi a basic set was made
while loads of puppeteers were in charge
of animating the creatures on set oh and
there were some practical vehicles
taking quite a beating as well the
landscapes and skylines we see
throughout the movies were created from
the ground up but on a computer
replicating each detail of the new york
skyline including buildings at scale
throw in some lights moody fog color and
some vehicles and carriages moving
through the city and you are set this
world of magic is full of special
effects and images like we've never
imagined and with such convincing cgi
it's easy to forget it's all a world of
fiction which creature in the series is
your favorite
foreign